Das ist wirklich jetzt der absolute haben wir die position vom planet 9 wurde eingegrenzt bisher blieb der phantom planet neuen jahr trotz
intensiver suche unentdeckt wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler haben aber jetzt seine exakte position
na ja mehr oder weniger mit hilfe komplexer mathematischer modellierung und
Computergestützte simulationen eingegrenzt jetzt hat die gezielte suche begonnen die schlinge um planet 9 zieht sich also immer weiter
Zu wo genau er sich wohl befindet und wann wir ihn wahrscheinlich endlich entdecken werden jetzt den klicks und science fiction herzlich willkommen
Planet neuen erinnert ein wenig an den planeten neptun auch
er wurde viele jahre vor seiner eigentlichen entdeckung theoretisch bereits vorher gesagt und zwar aufgrund von
unregelmäßigkeiten in der bahn
Des uranus ähnlich verhält es sich jetzt mit planet 9 trotz intensiver suche bleibt der riesen planet aber ein phantom
Dabei mangelt es nicht an verschiedensten anhaltspunkten und indizien man vermutet dass es sich dabei wohl. Um einen gesteinsplaneten
handelt und dass
Er wohl den vierfachen durchmesser der erde hat und maximal zehn mal so groß ist wie unser heimatplanet
er muss sich nach ansicht vieler
Forschungsteams wohl am äußeren rand des sonnensystems
versteckt halten
gemeinsame bahn abweichungen verschiedenste objekte in dieser region
Lassen darauf schliessen konkret geht es um rund 20 größere objekte
Im kupfergürtel ein gebiet außerhalb der neptun bahn nach schätzungen von astronomen und astronomen sind dort zahlreiche
kleine und wohl mehr als
70.000 objekte zu finden die einen durchmesser von mehr als 100 kilometern haben weswegen man planet 9 bis heute trotz
intensiver suche noch nicht direkt beobachten konnte das liegt wohl an seiner enormen distanz zur sondern amerikanische
wissenschaftler und wissenschaftlerinnen vom institute of technology
california haben jetzt berechnet dass die bahn verblendet neuen dem planeten zu dem zeitpunkt seiner dichtesten erdnähe wohl noch immer
achtung
700 mal weiter an der sonne vorbei führt als die erde das forschungsteam hat viele informationen über den mysteriösen
riesenplaneten analysiert und mit hilfe von co hüther modellen komplizierte simulationen erstellt ihr ziel ein
Computerprogramm soll ihn ganz konkret die position von planet neuen nennen so dass er dann ganz einfach mit einem
großteleskop entdeckt werden kann genauso wie damals bei neptun in einem blog artikel schreibt einer der beteiligten forscher mike brown dass sein team das
Komplette letzte jahr analysiert hat wie planet 9 mit anderen planeten und dem rest des
Sonnensystems interagiert zitat wir sind schon ein gutes stück weitergekommen seine mögliche position am himmel
einzugrenzen dieser ort befinden sich ziemlich nahm sternbild orion was eigentlich recht komisch ist da der orion schließlich zu den bekanntesten
sternbildern zählt die eigentlich fast jeder kennt zitat ende schon in naher zukunft wieder hoch genug
Am himmel steht will das forschungsteam mit der systematischen suche am himmel beginnt mike brown und seine kolleginnen und kollegen geben sich also
Äußerst zuversichtlich die exakte position des mysteriösen phantom planeten eingrenzen zu können
dennoch sagen sie auch dass sie zurzeit weniger
Informationen über die lage von kliniken haben als die astronomen und astronomen damals die im jahr
1846 neptun entdeckt haben das ergebnis ihrer forschung hat das amerikanische team online
Veröffentlicht denn sie wollen so heißt es in dem blog dass möglichst viele bei der suche helfen oder sind nicht wenige mindestens zehn weitere unabhängige
forscherinnen und forscher suchen derzeit fieberhaft
Nach planeten jäger geht es um halte ich euch natürlich
zu allen entwicklungen bei planet 9 auf dem laufenden wenn er kein video dazu verpassen wollte und auch
Zu allen anderen themen dann genau hier ein abo aufs auge und vergesst nicht den
Auf die gurke denn nur dann werdet ihr auch sicher informiert wenn es neue videos gibt und hier geht es weiter mit planeten nachgewiesen
Da gibt es weitere infos zu planet 9 wenn er mehr infos haben wollt draufklicken und ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran